As we jump to our next game, Sugar
Daddies.
If your beer-gutty buddies seem
unnervingly confident these days
that's because the latest trend
sweeping the Internet is dad
bod, the approach to fitness
that finally gives a catchy name
to being out of shape.
Though I say if you're gonna do
it, do it all the way and aim
for father bod.
Just go full bod-father on these
chumps.
Like this.
There we go.
>> Oh.
>> HARDWICK: For the
uninitiated...
>> The watch tan line is
beautiful.
That's a nice touch.
>> HARDWICK: It's like they
follow your eyes wherever you...
For the... for the uninitiated,
the Web site 8BitDad went so far
as to plan out the 30-day Dad
Bod Challenge, which features
mostly cheat days and drinking,
because you need reminders to do
that.
Uh, but I think this itinerary
is a little lacking.
So what are some other days that
should be part of the Dad Bod
Challenge?
In 60 seconds. And begin.
(bell dings)
Flula.
>> Day 22, bottle your toots,
sniff your toots.
Repeat.
>> HARDWICK: Points.
(bell dings)
Mamrie.
>> Day 20, ask your daughter
about Zach leaving One
Direction.
>> HARDWICK: Points.
(bell dings)
Rove.
>> Day 12, order UroClub.
>> HARDWICK: Points.
(bell dings)
Rove.
>> Day eight, ask your doctor if
Cialis is right for you.
>> HARDWICK: Points.
(bell dings)
Mamrie.
>> Day seven, have your children
regret teaching you how to text.
>> HARDWICK: Points.
(bell dings)
Flula.
>> Impress your daughter's
friends by telling them about
the time you sat next to Steven
Seagal at the Chili's in the
airport.
>> HARDWICK: Points.
(bell dings)
Rove.
>> Day 29, fart when you
[BLEEP].
>> HARDWICK: I've done that.
>> Wow.
>> HARDWICK: There's no way to
apologize for it.
(bell dings)
Mamrie.
>> Uh, day six, take a bite out
of a dog treat out of sheer
curiosity.
>> HARDWICK: Yes, points.
(bell dings)
Flula.
>> Eat the dog that you just ate
the dog treat from.